if you want it if you want to live the
life that you want to win they interest
always going to be more until you're
[ __ ] satisfied if you understand
business businesses need to evolve or
they all die no matter who they are that
I'm outrageously confident in because
that's all I know I don't know why one
would try to maximize money in the short
term for their inevitable death put in
your phone number right now and I will
answer one small business question while
I wait for this meeting I just snuck in
this little session look dude you can't
eat you could do anything as long as
you're producing content and
communicating to the right people
mmm like you could do anything it's
about creating the communications and
building awareness around it the work on
more [ __ ] I love that that was the
way honestly for all the people watching
now on Instagram the fact that that's
the way you answered it made my heart
smile yes if you want it if you want to
live the life that you want to win they
interest always going to be more until
you're [ __ ] satisfied
[Music]
if you really look back at early
restaurant behavior when Q SR is
McDonald's think the menus were
massively limited for the reasons they
were back then
and then what I want Wiis happens you
overextend yourself right I don't know
and I don't know the catering
capabilities the cooks like the details
but if you told me the people that make
our food like the one that's locked in
the cook she or he the single best thing
they do in the world is make a roast
beef sandwich I would create a
restaurant that's completely predicated
on the roast beef sandwich I would make
the roast beef sandwich that the famous
thing of you're catering because now you
got it nice and tight and you're using
the capabilities on both sides right
like all of this is gonna happen
especially in [ __ ] New York that's
all these [ __ ] characters want is a
singular expertise place like if you
told me right now the hottest restaurant
in Manhattan was ketchup and you go
there and you can catch up I'd be like
the [ __ ] hipsters right I actually
believed that would work what I just
said
because mainly because I know everybody
who come just for the Instagram photos
every your own by the way that's [ __ ]
amazing if you had a restaurant where
people are buying ketchup and people are
bringing other [ __ ] that'd be me and by
the way when I tell you New York would
fall for that like a [ __ ] they would
fold like a cheap chair everybody in my
office would go to that goddamn place I
mean guys I will just say this like when
I think about these ideas I always do
what I'm about to do we are sitting at a
table where there is bottled water
we paid multiple dollars for water in
that bottle which is literally free to
our selves right now if we go in the
kitchen I mean I'm I would pay anything
and I mean a lot just cuz I would want
to see it I'm trying to think how much I
would pay I would pay crazy amounts of
money if somebody said they actually had
the footage from the first time bottled
water was thought of I'm just dying to
see how she or he got laughed out of the
room
I mean oxygen is the only one like
that's the one that I want I know it
does versions up Bert yeah I've seen it
I've seen it I've seen it but I'm
talking just like you come into the room
and you can you leave look like
the way we like that is more
experiential there's like things going
on I'm talking like you come into my
place
it's called oxygen you walk in you pay
me two bucks just don't you leave no way
this is it
all right film it fill it this is really
it it's not filtered make sense it's not
it's pretty much to why we're in deep
trouble it's good I'm really happy how
about you know not care what other
people think but still be a good
listener and not be stubborn that's a
great question um you know like it's you
know that's you know it's funny what
came to me like the answer was like
practice you know just like do it yeah I
don't know listen to Pete like do it
yeah you know to me it's it's the Delta
of defense and offense
listening and not being stubborn means
taking action to other people's advice
for context defense is dwelling about
people judging you yeah [ __ ] other
people's opinions bro yeah especially
when they're coming from people that
haven't achieved what you've achieved
look if you weren't raised in a way of
confidence you need to surround yourself
with people that give you confidence
patience and you know I talked a lot
about it and most people don't yeah lack
of patience leads to terrible behavior
lack of patience is also a tell that you
care about other people's opinions like
I get it lack of patience comes when
you're trying to prove something with
somebody to me if you genuinely are not
waking up 90 85 percent of the time
pumped like like literally you're just
super like you know what's so funny
I was such a bad student and I so early
on deployed self-awareness that school
wasn't for me I lived a decade of my
life knowing what it felt like to dwell
every morning look forward to Friday
love vacations and then when I became a
professional and did what I always
wanted to do and Here I am working a
super hard 21 years later I still wake
up so invigorated I think people have to
ask themselves are they actually happy
eight out of ten days when they wake up
and if they're not they need to pressure
on themselves to make themselves realize
they're probably not doing what they
want to be doing and and then the next
question becomes are you doing a job
just afford your lifestyle and are you
willing like I'm getting so passionate
about teaching people how to sell their
home and go rent so that they can quit a
job where they make 200 thousand a year
so they can take one that makes eighty
nine thousand cuz they'll be happy and
what did you give up telling people you
own your home so I mean I think it's a
very I think when you hear me say that
like I don't know I haven't heard
anybody talking about that and I think
it's so right what right like like
nobody's out there like hey sell your
home and start renting so that you can
quit a job that you hate so that you
could afford to maybe do something you
love but I think happiness over
everything like the American Dream
should not be owning a home the American
Dream should be to be happy
I mean it's just so funny like saving
money is like the most foreign I don't
god I just said that and I'm like have I
even heard somebody say that in the last
like if you're so passionate to build
your business how about you don't spend
all your money to sustain a lifestyle
that you're mainly doing to impress
people you don't even like and how about
you save some of it
I mean and this has led me down a lot of
places like is buying a home a good idea
like I've gotten into very interesting
places like the propaganda of the
American Dream is to own a home is
fascinating to me I'm really starting to
go down that path I'm like like I'm
trying to convince people to sell their
homes and rent and take the arbitrage
and use that money like what really
happens what you're sad that like you
can't tell some but your mom that you
don't own a home like I'm I've gotten
you know I you know I mean I've done
well for myself I haven't upgraded my
New York City apartment because I'm
living my thesis I'm like why but why
like it takes capital out of the system
for me to do things so like it's
definitely like it's very interesting to
me of how many things are accepted that
made sense post-world War two and make
absolutely no sense in 2019 and
basically the far majority of this room
and people watching on video their their
their behaviors at this at this macro
level are predicated on appeasing one or
two people in their lives Jason
[Music]